so whether you're a pro in the kitchen
or
you need some help like me a pastry
master class is a great christmas gift
for the entire family chef patrice
caillou executive pastry chef of win las
vegas and encore is here to tell us how
they're turning people into
master treat tremors this weekend right
yes absolutely absolutely so what is
street trimming so we're going to we
invite a lot of people especially kids
yeah five and older i love that it's an
entire family yeah it's very friendly
we're going to do a lot of cookies we're
going to do actually gingerbread house
we're going to decorate them beautiful i
can show you we can we have some piping
bags
so you see we have some some sample
so you have green the good thing about
the class is no you do whatever you want
yeah you can get creative right that's
the beauty of it you don't have to
follow the design but you can do your
own design okay good because your design
over here is actual perfection and i'm
not going to achieve that so if you take
your
your little pastry bag okay you see you
can go and
let the icing drop like that slowly
i'm gonna do a little gingerbread guy
there we go
and you keep going like that
wow so on the glass we're going to give
them a lot of treats also to eat oh my
gosh
you're so bad so oh that's not bad
oh my goodness
we have a little trick oh okay tell me
please tell me all the tricks
if you want to do the mouth
oh you just trace it let's see everybody
let's see we have a little trick we're
going to give you a lot of tricks we're
going to make them drink if they want
egg mugs
hot chocolate
so it's not just a cooking class or
baking class you actually get to enjoy
treats as you
make absolutely absolutely it's an
experience you know so and by the way i
have a question patrice yes this was a
pen but it wasn't a regular pen right no
it's an edible ink so edible ink people
okay
all right make the little detail like
the mouse the eyes if you want so you
see you can change the color uh-huh i
have some red
i can do a little
ornament on it little red heart here you
know and again it's not nothing it's uh
you can do whatever you want oh wow nice
you like my heart very nice
that's beautiful okay so by the way
we're making these treats and of course
they're edible and you can eat them and
give them as gifts but one cool thing
you can do with them is hang them on the
tree right absolutely how can we do that
so
the under class we're going to give you
some cookies and some of them will have
a little hole
before we bake the cookies we'll make
the hole and after you just have to take
a little piece of ribbon
put a full string and you just hang on
the tree they look really nice
just love it my kids are they can eat
them after you open your gifts right yes
okay so how can people join the class
saturday and beyond because there's a
full list absolutely we do a lot of
class usually monthly or sometimes the
only days we do more class okay you can
go on the website you can go on the win
website and you're going to see all the
information but please come and uh enjoy
the class come with your family come
with the kids it's really fun hold yours
up with mine hold yours up with mine
before we catch a break look at that
guys there we go there we go some
masters here treat trump